hi Matt here and I am super excited to
share that you can now use think fast
talk smart the podcast to help learn
English many of our Global listeners
enjoy our podcast for communication tips
and to improve their English fluency
starting with our most current episode
we're adding a brief English lesson with
each episode highlighting vocabulary and
idioms we also offer direct access to
our transcripts for easy reference and
review please visit faster smarter dot
IO slash learn English faster smarter.io
slash learn English
presence is incredibly important and
Powerful in communication
but in order to develop a strong
presence you first have to be present
with yourself
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
today I'm excited to speak with Muriel
Wilkins mural is an executive coach
author and podcast host along with Amy
Sue Muriel wrote the book own the room
discover your signature voice to master
your leadership presence and she hosts
the hbr podcast coaching real leaders
welcome Muriel I am excited for our chat
and can't wait to get started
I'm delighted to be here Matt great well
let's get going like me you've been a
coach for a number of years in your
coaching experience what are some of the
most common communication pitfalls that
leaders fall into and how can we avoid
them so I think the ones that I've seen
folks struggle with or not even be aware
of in terms of their communication
techniques or threefold the first is
just not having clarity about the
outcome they're looking to achieve
through their communication and so you
know what do you do about that spend
some time trying to get clear on what it
is exactly that you're trying to get
across the second which is a common and
often talked about is listening and just
having a lack of self-awareness around
what it means to listen am I listening
am I not so even just starting from that
place can really help and then lastly I
would say it is about checking your
assumptions before opening your mouth so
I think a big challenge for people is
they just start talking
and they haven't really checked their
assumptions what are their assumptions
about themselves about the other person
or the other people or the situation and
are those the assumptions that are going
to best serve them in that particular
conversation so it sounds to me like
what makes a lot of sense for leaders to
do and anybody to do is really before
you enter into an interaction especially
one that's scheduled and planned is to
really think about what is it I'm trying
to get done here and and what are the
assumptions and ideas I'm bringing that
might help or get in the way and then in
the moment listening becomes really
important
absolutely absolutely and it doesn't
take as long as most people think you
can do that as you're walking to a
meeting or as you're just transitioning
from one to the other or as you're
getting ready for your day and a lot of
us are so busy and rushing around we
don't have time to do what you're
suggesting and I have found in my own
life and the work I do just in teaching
or coaching it helps just to take a
moment to reflect on those things it
helps Center you in and get you present
which which I assume also is very
helpful yeah absolutely
in your book own the room you emphasize
the importance of authentic presence for
leaders can you define what you mean by
presence and how does communication play
a role in building in showing presence
sure I mean karisa Fang like everybody
has presence you know I think the
question really is is a is it the
presence that you want to have is this
how you want others to experience you
and then secondly you know looking
specifically at leadership is it
leadership presence so is your presence
one that exudes leadership regardless of
where you fall in the organizational
hierarchy and so when I talk about
leadership presence it really is this
ability not only to demonstrate your
value and be clear about your message in
an authentic way but also to connect
with others and it's at that
intersection where you can both be
credible in terms of what you share as
well as relatable because you can
connect with others that we have found
individuals feel like they are in the
presence of a leader and so that's what
we mean when we talk about having
authentic leadership presence
I I love this idea of credible and
relatable so let's dive into this what
are some rules that I can do or a leader
can do to establish credibility I mean I
can come and tell you all these great
things I've done but but that almost
sounds braggadocious that doesn't sound
like it's being authentic and relatable
what are things that we can do to
demonstrate both credibility and
relatability sure so let's break those
apart and so for the credibility
standpoint you have to start with how do
I add value in this particular
interaction is it by having a point of
view is it by listening is it by asking
questions so you prove your credibility
or demonstrate credibility by bringing
something to the table and so it really
starts by being clear about what it is
that you actually bring to that table in
that particular venue
and then in terms of communication
skills it's a lot about of what you talk
about being able to speak in a clear
concise structured Manner and that takes
practice you know it's a skill that
anyone can build but it does take some
practice to be able to get there to be
able to talk with that level of
preciseness on the connecting side
listening is the biggest skill when you
think about when others feel heard or
valued or understood it's usually
because somebody has listened to them
before they start talking or as they
respond and so that's really the biggest
communication skill that can help on the
connecting site listening is so critical
the more and more I do this work the
more listening becomes just essential
Matt this is why I often say when I talk
to my clients or if I'm speaking to
groups that when you think about having
Presence at the root of it it's your
ability to be present enough in the
moment so that you know what
communication skills to use that will
help you get to the outcome that you're
looking to get to whatever that might be
and so it's this level of forget the
preparation forget what's going to
happen afterwards but can you be present
enough in the moment and that present
enough in the moment is what allows you
to then have presence I'm smiling as you
say that it's one of these things that I
should have realized eons ago but
presence I've always thought about how
others see you but what you've just
defined as presence is also about being
present so you can respond as necessary
and to me that was an epiphany that just
happened in your presence so thank you
and it's just as important that you also
start with how you you experience
yourself absolutely you know before you
move to so being present is how am I
experiencing myself in this moment and
is that what I want it to be or need it
to be in order to move the conversation
ahead or whatever it might be right you
have to be present so you can have
presence
So speaking of presence imposter
syndrome is something that I and a lot
of people I coach and teach suffer from
what are your thoughts on imposter
syndrome and and how can we manage it oh
my goodness I have so many thoughts in
there forever evolving around imposter
syndrome imposter syndrome is really
this notion of feeling or not feeling
like one belongs whether it's in a
meeting in a conversation in a room in a
position
and it's a little complex because it's a
two-way street it's how do I feel in
this particular situation and do I feel
like I belong but there's also the
context that you're in and does that
context make me feel like I belong but
in my work as a coach and I know Matt
for you too I'm always focused on the
person that I'm coaching so if they're
dealing with imposter syndrome it's
what's within your control and part of
it is getting out of their own way
around the assumptions that they have
that they don't belong which is what
leads to the Imposter syndrome and so we
tend to lift out and redefine it and say
well what would make you feel what is in
your control that would make you feel
like you belong at table and it often
comes back to this notion of how do I
add value I want to create value I want
to contribute how do I do that in a way
that makes me feel like I am here
because I am here right so imposterous
syndrome I think is often talked about
in terms of like here are the three
steps you can take but I think it goes
back to this fundamental need of we all
have a desire to belong and so we have
to Define what that looks like for each
one of us and then translate that into a
meeting setting or a conversational
setting whatever that might be
transforming imposter syndrome to being
about belonging I think is really really
useful it allows us to find ways that we
can belong and that can make us feel
better and therefore not as if we don't
fit in I find in my own life in the work
I do that a lot of imposter syndrome is
based on comparing comparing ourselves
to others or comparing ourselves to the
standard that we hold in our head for
what odor should be do you have
techniques that help people either find
a different comparison or stop comparing
altogether yeah I mean I think you know
there's a quote that says comparison is
the thief of joy you know and I
fundamentally believe that now does it
mean that you don't pay attention to
what's going on around you you do pay
attention to it you pay attention I mean
this is the way the world works but you
can also separate from it and
distinguish it I think a lot of people
base their sense of belonging and have
it be dependent on others accepting them
those are two separate things I can
belong somewhere and still not have
others accept me and so I think I try
with my clients to get them to
understand that there's a distinction
between the two and let's focus on your
sense of belonging which really often
has nothing to do you know like if I
think about myself as a black woman
walking into a room I can feel like I
don't belong but that's because of what
I've experienced in the past yet it's in
my control to say regardless of what
people think about me I belong here so
it starts with myself now whether they
accept me or not that's on them now let
me see if there's any way I can
influence that in a way that still
resonates with me and doesn't feel like
I'm selling my soul but that's where the
work becomes so I think just
distinguishing between the two from a
mindset standpoint is very important and
then once you start moving into how do I
make sure that I can try to be relevant
for this audience that's the other way
that I try to think about it then it
becomes the communication skills that
we've talked about particularly around
establishing credibility
so this notion of belonging acceptance
comparison really important to think
about that there are those are levers
that we can pull and they're distinct
and it strikes me that we talked a few
moments ago about presence about being
present in the moment but some of the
ways we've just talked about to manage
imposter syndrome are to First distance
yourself reflect on how can I belong how
can I build acceptance how can I change
what and who I compare to and then go
into the situation where you are present
so sometimes being present is key and
sometimes giving yourself a little space
and Grace can be really helpful yeah and
any Matt the way I think about it is it
is promoting space and it's creating
distance between you and the external
you and the outcome possibly which means
that you need to go internal and so it's
being more present to yourself you don't
lose the presence of being more present
to yourself first before your present to
what's going on out there thank you for
that distinction absolutely I see that
and I appreciate that clarification
you're exactly right we have to be
present with ourselves distancing from
others at first and then we can really
engage and be present thank you I know
framing is something that you feel is
very useful in communication can you
help us understand what you mean by
Framing and give us some examples of how
we can use framing in our communication
yes so I think framing is one of the
most powerful communication skills and
yet most underutilized ones framing is
really about setting context and when I
observe my clients even when they
communicate with me I can count more
than I would like the number of times
they start sharing without setting
context so why do you need to set
context I mean the word framing
literally comes it's like you have a
piece of art
the piece of art will resonate with you
differently depending on the frame that
is around it so this isn't about
spinning or manipulating the message the
frame is the frame is the frame like it
still needs to be true it's still the
data needs to still hold but the frame
that you choose the context that you
choose to introduce whatever it is that
you're presenting is going to help
influence how others interpret whatever
it is that you're trying to communicate
and so the types of framing you can use
you can frame your message strategically
that's particularly helpful if you're
communicating up to those more senior
than you you want to set the context in
a way that it's going to be relevant for
whatever business strategy outcomes
they're trying to achieve another type
of framing is through metaphors or
storytelling you set the context by
telling a story or by using a metaphor
what that does is simplify the message
and brings it to life for the audience
that you're dealing with that's
extremely helpful if you're trying to
communicate technical content to a
non-technical audience so framing all it
is about is setting the table and giving
it some context rather than just spewing
the data out and assuming that they're
going to understand it in the same way
that you do framing is critical I
totally agree and as you said it's all
about setting context and framing can
come down literally to the language you
use I I will talk with people I work
with and teach about framing something
as a problem versus an opportunity you
can take the same circumstance and frame
it one way or the other based on what
you think will resonate most with the
audience but you're so right people just
spew information and they don't set the
context or frame that can help people
decipher what's meant help give us a
step forward towards your goal in terms
of persuasion or influence so framing is
very critical yeah and even framing you
know the what you shared there's also
like should you frame something as an
assertion versus a question absolutely I
often talk about feedback as an
opportunity to problem solve and if you
provide feedback as a question you can
reduce defensiveness you can build
engagement now that doesn't work all the
time but you're right a certain versus
questioning very powerful
like you many of our listeners find
themselves in coaching and mentoring
roles what are some of the techniques
that you use to help draw out
information from the people you coach
and what are some of the techniques you
use when providing constructive or
counter-intuitive guidance and feedback
you know I've been doing this for a very
very long time coaching that is almost
20 years and I find that there's three
particular skills that I really bring to
bear in coaching number one is the
ability to listen and not just listen
for what's being said but listen for
what are the different interpretations
of what could be said so that I can help
my clients get awareness I think
secondly the ability to ask questions
and questions are not in an
interrogative way I think questions that
just follow the conversation open up the
conversation really so that my clients
can help understand what the choices are
in front of them
and then the third to be when we get to
this point of real feedback the third is
to be able to be direct with them Direct
in terms of what I'm hearing direct
around my assessment of how I think they
might be interpreting something direct
at times around suggestions you know
that are obviously always their choice
in terms of what to do but direct enough
I'm not a coach who stays and like
listening and asking questions all the
time I will provide suggestions but it's
you know as I hear said sometimes it's
my suggestions their decision what they
want to do and so when it comes to
feedback I think what's particularly
helpful is using the skill of framing
right it's providing the feedback in a
way that is going to be relevant to them
that is going to resonate with them and
so I often ground my feedback in
something that they may have mentioned
already and something that they say is
important to them or something that I
know is coming up that is of value to
them it sounds like you're doing a lot
of work and it sounds like some of that
work you do in advance but some you're
adjusting and adapting in the moment
well Muriel I would be missing a huge
opportunity if I didn't ask for your
expert coaching advice like you do on
your coaching real leaders podcast would
you be willing to coach me on a
challenge that I often face absolutely
my challenge is having trouble setting
boundaries and saying No I say yes way
too often and get myself in trouble
because I then have too much to do how
would you help me in that circumstance
well let me ask you a question how does
that help you to say yes all the time I
have learned in my life that when I say
yes good things can happen and I have
benefited from being willing to take
risks and to explore opportunities the
downside is it swamps me in terms of the
things I have to do
yeah and so on the downside what is it
that you would say no to in hindsight
there are many things that I have taken
on that turned out to be much more work
than I expected or turned out to be
false starts that didn't lead to
anything I don't want to say they were a
waste of time because I think I learned
something from them but had I had an
opportunity to make that choice again I
would definitely choose a different
answer than the yes that I gave then
what would have helped you make that
choice I think honestly just taking a
moment to reflect and I think the
reflection is
to really think about how much is
involved and the struggle and
prioritization I would have to do if I
really took this on I am somebody who
gets really excited about potential
opportunities and I often don't take the
time to think about the consequences of
oh this would be really cool but you
know what it's going to take a lot of
time and it's going to mean you're not
going to be able to do these other
things that you've either committed to
or excited about yeah I mean what I hear
you saying Matt is maybe expanding from
I get excited about a lot of things too
am I getting excited about the right
things at the right time and so the
excitement is not in question right we
want to keep that going but maybe it's
taking some space to really Define for
yourself for a period of time for a
season what are the right things that I
want to pour that excitement into and
how much time do I want to pour into
them and that can change year to year in
fact I advise many of my clients to take
stock of that periodically and that is
prioritizing basically so I think
overlaying it with priorities will then
help give you a filter and a framework
for what do I say yes to and what do I
say no to in a responsive way rather
than in a reactive way which your your
default reaction is yes right so if you
have those two columns right in front of
you it can help then structure your
thinking about it as those situations
come up thank you you helped me see
something that I think will be
transformative I've been looking at the
world as binary yes or no but what I
heard from you what really clicked in my
mind this notion of not yet so maybe
it's not a no but it's not now that will
be helpful to to think of set time
frames and maybe something that's really
exciting to me I simply say great but
not now maybe I look at that later and
adding is a choice so it's not yes no
it's yes no and not now that will help
me thank you you are really good
so before we end Muriel I'd like to ask
you the same three questions I ask
everyone who joins me are you up for
that sure all right question number one
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title what would it be leadership
is about asking the right questions not
having the right answer it's about
asking the right questions not having
the right answers and that really turns
what many of us think about leadership
on its head we think people expect us to
have the right answers but in fact
asking those questions is more powerful
question number two who is a
communicator you admire and why oh my
goodness there are so many but I'm just
gonna go with who's popping up in my
mind right now it's Pema shodron
she is a writer a spiritual teacher a
speaker a meditation teacher and
the reason she's popping up in my mind
is she is able to take what I consider
what can feel complex in terms of
content and topics that can feel very
out of touch and simplify them in a way
that you get the message
and she does that through storytelling
and when you hear her speak there is a
level of presence in terms of being
present in the moment that is palpable
that I think enables her to do that and
it's such an authentic way that I find
very very powerful wonderful the ability
to be present the ability to make
complex information accessible are true
gifts to the audience and that's
wonderful
final question question number three
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe number one Clarity number two
relevance particularly to the audience
but also for yourself
and number three I couldn't leave this
one out presents
what I like about all three of your
suggestions is they apply to the
audience right Clarity relevance and
presence you need that for your audience
but you also need it for yourself
excellent very very helpful as was
everything you shared Muriel thank you
so much for joining us thank you for
providing insights into communication
leadership and presence and personally
thank you for helping me with a
challenge that I have you are an expert
coach and if you want to learn more
about Muriel and her coaching I
encourage you to listen to the hbr
podcast coaching real leaders thank you
so much thank you Matt
[Applause]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn